yeah so hi Ryan Williams from hammer lab
this is gonna be kind of a sprint so I'm
gonna try to get through a lot of
material just call out if something
doesn't make sense we'll do a quick
intro a genomics crash course I'll talk
about this tool called guacamole which
is something that I've worked on a lot
at hammer Lab and if we have time which
we probably won't some other interesting
applications of sort of like distributed
compute on genomic data so yeah Wes
talked a little bit about hammer lab
when Jeff started it like three years
ago a big focus was writing tools to
analyze genome data because there's just
a lot of it there's a lot of opportunity
to apply sort of distributed systems
best practices to improve some of the
workflows that exist in that space we've
over the years really moved into a lot
of applications and they cancer
immunotherapy realm cancer is most of
the genome sequencing that happens is
targeted at diagnosing or treating
cancer cancer is a disease of the genome
so it's kind of like the main
application for a lot of the cool
sequencing technology let's come out
over the last like 15 years we
prioritize writing high quality open
source software which you can find on
our github okay so quick genomics
sequencing crash course you have a
trillion cells in your body and each one
has a full copy of your DNA which is
like three billion bases a base is one
of four molecules ACG RT for short and
you have sort of it's it's wrapped in
two strands the information is kind of
redundant on each strand which is part
of how the whole replication process
works you can split the two strands and
they can kind of be reconstituted
separately from one another it's sort of
like nature's trick for doing a
replication that underpins all of life
the DNA is really fundamentally
information it is a like linear
representation of you can it's analogous
to source code that cell basically just
sort of like opens up different parts of
and runs the programs that are described
there to do all the work of being
a cell and we want to read that source
code fundamentally is the problem the
DNA is packaged into chromosomes there
are 22 in a human cell there's actually
two copies of each chromosome there and
each one is maybe a hundred million
bases long so if you if you laid them
out and to end it would be like a
football field long but they're actually
sort of packaged into a cell that's like
a micrometer in diameter so it's like an
amazing kind of feat of physical fractal
compression you start with sort of like
winding in a helix and then the helix
sort of winds in a super helix and then
that super helix winds in a super super
helix and you have like sort of ten
orders of magnitude of like packaging
this information into a very small
volume we're sort of like we don't
actually don't even know what the shape
of a couple of those middle order orders
of magnitude is they're just like super
intricate tightly packed molecules super
dense with information that we want to
read and we mostly can we would love to
be able to just read these chromosomes
end-to-end no one's figured out a way to
do that for the purposes of this talk
all we can do is read a hundred base
long fragments of DNA whereas the
chromosomes we're trying to read are
like a hundred million bases long so
basically what we do is take a bunch of
copies of the DNA and just shatter it
into tiny bits that we can read and then
we try to reconstitute those bits into a
picture of the original genome
everything from the middle of this slide
onwards in the pipeline is entirely
computational right the sequencing
machine gets us from the the top row and
some stuff predating them out of how we
the sort of like still the cells into
just the DNA and like do the shattering
and the reading and then you know
reconstituting these like small
sequences into the larger sequence is
interesting computational problem I'll
talk a little bit about there's a few
other downstream steps that I'll try to
quickly overview the
the sort of color scheme here implies a
global uniqueness property to some of
the sequence that doesn't really exist
it's much messier than this so just
quickly kind of back to the envelope
talking about what it takes to store and
process human genome data in ideal and
real-world settings so as I mentioned
you have three billion bases you can
sort of think of each one as one of four
possibilities which can be represented
by two bits so you'd have four bases per
byte so three billion bases would take
up about 750 megabytes of space a
optimization or observation is that far
less than 1% of that sequence is unique
from person to person so if you were
trying to store like many genomes
together you could sort of compress
those down in a way where each marginal
genome might only offer a sort of like 7
megabytes of new information and in the
sort of information theoretic sense so
you could kind of squint and imagine
storing like everyone in the world's
genomes and like some tens of petabytes
of data of course like having one giant
gzip file with everyone's genome in it
wouldn't be any of any use to anyone so
you'd want sort of data structures and
algorithms that operate on those data
structures that don't exist yet and
that's sort of an area of research it's
all very interesting not really that
connected to what happens in practice
today what we get is all of these DNA
fragments like a billion of them that
are 100 bases long so it's like a
hundred billion total sequence bases and
that's enough to cover a three billion
base pair genome at about 30 X depth so
like on average any position in the
genome will have like 30 fragments
overlapping it that you can sort of
looked at hopefully there's a clear
consensus about whether the person has
an a CG or T there it's kind of the game
of course you know some reasons we'll
have less coverage in some regions we'll
have more and so that's 30 is sort of
like the standard that we do that sort
of trades off the cost of marginally
more sequencing against the like benefit
of the information the marginal
information you get these bases we get
off the sequencing machine don't just
have the two bits representing the a CG
or T they also come with a quality score
that
how sure the sequencing machine is that
of the of the guests it's made about
whether that base is an AC G or T so now
you're looking at more like a byte per
sequence space that you're storing and
so you're quickly more in the realm of
like 100 gigabytes to store one person's
genome and so like large-scale
sequencing projects these days might
deal with 100 to 100,000 genomes so
you're quickly in sort of like cluster
scale compute realms where you don't
want to just be doing this on a server
under your desk brief overview of just
like the recent history of sequencing
human genomes the human genome project
took 13 years and a hundred million
dollars 13 years ago later there was a
thousand genomes project that was a few
years and still like doing marginal work
took like four years in the British
government is currently doing a hundred
thousand genomes project a lot of people
have seen this slide which is just like
a precipitous drop in the cost of
sequencing over time the end of this
slide is sort of like or this graph is
kind of like you start to run into a lot
of marketing speak from the sequencing
companies they get sort of actually like
plateaued for the last several years and
it's given I think everyone in the space
of a chance to maybe catch their breath
and wait for the next like breakthrough
in sequencing technology to upend
everything but either way there's no
doubt that the number of genomes being
sequences just like skyrocketing and
we're quickly going to live in a world
if we don't already live in one we're
like on the order of millions of genomes
have been sequenced if we're talking
about 100 gigabytes per genome like it's
just like where's everyone putting that
data can we ask questions of all of it
at the same time today the answer is
like resoundingly no to those questions
so it's just like some of those things
are things that my lab thinks about okay
so the first part of the genome analysis
pipeline is we have all these fragments
and we need to reconstitute the genome
just gonna try to breeze through a
couple observations about that the
genome is kind of a mess the human
genome all of them actually they're just
like all kinds of evolutionary detritus
laying around
excessive repetitive structure makes it
really hard if you only have these like
small sort of windows that you get to
see
to figure out what's actually there 20
percent of the human genome is
retrotransposons which is basically
these like parasitic bits of DNA that
just encode they are the source code for
a program that when the cell runs it
just makes a copy of that source code
and puts it somewhere else in the genome
so you've got there's like one of those
that you have at 7,000 bases long and
there's a hundred thousand copies of
that just laying around just being
junked and taking up space so it's just
you know it's like not intelligently
designed she might say like it's it's a
disaster and it's especially given like
what I've described at how the
sequencing platforms work it makes it
really hard to figure out what's
actually going on pseudogenes is like a
marginally less sort of Annoying version
of this where like an entire useful
functional gene was copied at some point
to some other chromosome perhaps and now
you have two copies they can just sort
of drift evolutionarily and so you have
like large amounts of sequence that are
just like really similar but not totally
identical and so it just makes things
really interesting when you're trying to
reconstruct these genomes with short
reads everyone's still basically with me
anyone want to call out a question have
I glossed over anything it didn't make
sense yeah you try to reconstruct these
genomes by just stitching together the
overlaps of these like small fragments
of DNA you have these like repetitive
regions that have many branches in and
out so you get yourself all tied and
knots people have made beautiful pieces
of software that let you visualize just
how hoes do you are in these situations
so you kind of can't do it from scratch
so the the state of the art or what is
usually done in practice is we use a
reference genome which is like some
consortium of people spent a lot of
extra money to sequence a genome in a
bunch of more complex ways and sort of
validate it in a bunch of ways that lets
them get see longer than 100 bases in
any direction so they have like
reasonably high confidence that we have
like a mostly complete whole genome
sequence as an aside there's like parts
of the genome that no one ever has ever
successfully sequence they're just like
bundled too tightly like the middles of
the chromosomes tend to be just like
wound up so tight so it's a bit of like
mission accomplished syndrome with like
all of the like proclamations that we
like every even sequence a whole genome
there's like just unresolved bits but
whatever we have a good enough reference
and so we just take these little bits
and we align them to the place on the
reference that it seems like they map if
that is if it's sort of unambiguous then
that's great if it's not maybe we just
throw them away the good news is like
most of the genome actually sort of like
you look at 100 base pair window and
it's like basically unique so you can
take one of these segments and
everyone's genome is similar enough to
everyone else is that like most of them
just kind of match so what this view is
showing is that all of these gray bars
in the middle are reads that have been
mapped and they are grey everywhere that
they match the reference so like
everything in this picture basically
matches except for like a couple random
errors basically that you can look at
they're sort of they look like noise
they're just like the sequencing machine
made a mistake there right like like
here it's thought this read has an a the
reference has to see clearly all these
other reads that that all map to the
same context as that read just match a
bunch of bases in every direction so
this is just an error of the sequencing
machine made so that brings us to
variant calling like at this point oK
we've mapped all the fragments we want
to actually go through and find the
places where it is different from the
reference that's sort of what the point
is of sequencing a person's genome so
this is an example of what that would
look like here we have the reference
genome on the bottom and all the reads
in the picture basically matches the
reference everywhere except at this one
position all the reads say that the
person has a see when the reference set
T so that is like as clean as it could
be this person has that T to C mutation
there and you hand that downstream to a
clinician who can look at what gene it's
in like does that do anything maybe
probably not in most cases sometimes yes
so and we call that a variant or a
mutation it sounds like a kind of
pejorative term it's just an observation
of like a diff aligned in a diff if you
will so it's in general it's slightly
more complicated because you have two
copies of every chromosome so almost
every mutation
it's gonna just happen on one of the
copies and not the other so the more
sort of like Platonic ideal of a variant
looks more like this where again
everything in the picture matches the
reference great except for this one
place where the reference has a red is T
I think and yellow is G so we have like
about half of the reads have a G and the
other half have a T which matches the
reference so that's like a pretty clear
case where one of the chromosomes has
this T 2g mutation and the other has
just the reference T so we would look at
that and call that heterozygous variant
again this is a mercifully clean example
so much more complicated problem and the
one that I spend a lot of my time
thinking about is somatic mutation
calling so in this case we're not just
sequencing like one population of cells
like just that we've taken from a person
and comparing it to a reference we are
sequencing two populations from a given
person so the common case would be like
we are sequencing some tumor cells from
a cancer patient and also some normal
cells and what we are interested in are
the mutations that are specific to their
tumor cells you know we sort of conceive
of each of the populations have cell in
isolation as like a diff from some
reference and we really want the diff of
these two dips to figure out what is
specific to the tumor cells because then
that can potentially tell us about
things that have a you know clinical
relevance to how that person will be
treated so here's sort of clean example
of what that might look like so we have
the reference genome on top we have a
bunch of reads from the normal cells in
on the also on the top slightly below
the reference and then the the tumor
reads show that about half of them have
a C whereas the reference and the normal
cells have a G so this looks like a
somatic mutation in the the tumor cells
maybe like again one of the two
chromosomes in the tumor cells has this
mutation and then you know we so we
flagged that and then like downstream
like are there kind of like things we
can infer about where it is in the
genome is it likely to be causing any of
the problems causing the cancer or is it
just incidental um here's an example
where like
seven bases are just deleted so the so I
guess like it's my curse yeah cool
so like the normal reads match the
reference which is down here at the
bottom it has a G this is like the
primary tumor looks like half of the
reads show like seven bases being
deleted and then like down here this is
from a recurrence sample which probably
means like maybe some chemotherapy or
something was administered and then they
sequence the cancer cells that are left
after or that come back after the cancer
has recurred and in this case you might
sort of squint and say like well it was
only only half of the cells had that
deletion originally and now that it
looks kind of like they all do so it
could be that that deletion allowed the
cancer cells to escape from the
chemotherapy that was applied those are
kinds of questions that we want to
answer so somatic mutation is really
hard because cancer is just the regular
genome is a mess and cancer is like way
worse it's just like kind of hyper in a
hyper mutating state and it's got its
a-hole own family tree with subclones
that have their own mutations that can
exist at arbitrary fractions of the
overall population and at the end of the
day we just don't have with the
sequencing technology we have we can't
really resolve this stuff perfectly and
to make matters worse like often when we
see when we sequence tumor samples we
have normal cells mixed in with them so
like if you see like half of the reads
and a tumor sample show a mutation you
don't know if that's like 100% of the
tumor cells reads have that mutation and
but you just had half the population was
actually normal cells that got mixed in
there by mistake or if actually it was
all tumor cells and just half of them
have that mutation so so so it's a hard
problem and it's basically you're only
going to do as well as sort of like the
Bayesian models and other like guesses
that you make so there's like a lot of
tools that try to do this and they
mostly don't agree with each other
there's like I have like a lot of just
parameters that tune their sort of
Bayesian models they apply to these
situations and they're very sensitive to
what parameters you set and a sort of
second order problem that they have is
that they take a really long time to run
so people mostly just run them once with
one set of parameters like you know that
probably the results you get are very
sensitive to the parameters you picked
but are you going to run it again and
wait land
five hours like you know what would it
even tell you I don't know
why don't any of these things agree it
takes too long to run nobody has time
for that so that was like a lot of the
motivation for writing guacamole which
is this somatic mutation caller that
we've built over the last few years that
runs on spark and that we run we on our
Hadoop cluster at non sorry okay cool so
that was the end of the genomics crash
course portion of the talk so the the
records we're dealing with in guacamole
are essentially like the there's 100
base pair of DNA fragments and what we
want to do is basically just step over
them like in those visualizations I
showed you and basically for a given
genomic locus consider all the reads
that overlap that locus count how many
matches the reference how many don't and
just sort of like look at some other
context about the reads like does this
read have a lot of errors maybe
something's wrong with it anyway and we
want to throw it out like yada yada yada
that's sort of like step four is like
the application logic so the interesting
thing here for the purposes of what what
I work on and this talk is sort of like
steps one through three where we take
these like these DNA fragments that have
been mapped to genomic intervals and we
kind of just like build these sort of
like what are called pile ups where it's
just for a given locus all the reads
that overlap that locus in a massively
parallel way so that we can do it
quickly in a way that's easier to Aude
it so the way that works is we basically
you know when we split up all of the
genomic loci and the reads that cover
them onto different partitions that we
can sort of just like map over in
parallel we the main thing we want to
avoid is like excessive skew because
like the underlying data is super skewed
like it's just common to have like some
parts of the genome where like a ton of
reads overlap those lows I and others
we're not that many overlaps so the the
blue bars in this graph are kind of
representing that so we can we sort of
do a we do a first pass over the reads
where for each of the 100 Llosa that I
give and read overlaps we can omit just
like that lo sy comma one and we just do
word count which SPARC makes very easy
we can get a
sort of distributed representation of
like a low sigh comma number of reads
that overlap it and then we and we sort
of have those organized by like in
sorted order so we can sort of step
through those low sigh and coverage
counts and sort of aggregate the low
sigh into contiguous ranges that we can
sort of like a sign as a partition that
in the next step we will then take all
of the genomic reads that overlap any of
these partitions and send them there if
that makes sense you don't have any
questions so far
cool so having having come up with a
partitioning in this step that we think
will sort of evenly spread out the reads
when they are mapped according to that
partitioning we then send the reads to
the partitions that have been assigned
the low-side that those reads overlap
this is one thing that makes dealing
with this kind of data tricky is that
because they are sort of their sort of
ordered and they are intervals you can
you almost anywhere you draw a partition
boundary in the genome you're gonna have
many reads sort of straddling that
boundary so as part of your partitioning
logic you need to send the reads that
overlap those boundaries to multiple
partitions so it creates sort of a like
temporary dicey state in terms of the
abstractions that spark presents and
that you would normally have like and
just like in a Hadoop MapReduce setting
where it's like you have this like large
data collection where for one of the
intermediate steps here like some of the
elements in there have been duplicated
in a way that's like very tied to how
they are partitioned at that moment that
we're going to resolve like in the next
step but all that having been done we
basically can then stream through like
each look each partition in parallel can
sort of go it has all of the reads or at
least a copy of every read that overlaps
any locus that has been assigned to that
partition and so we can kind of like
have our mappers just like stream
through those partitions full of the
read copies and at each position just
perform some logic on the pile ups that
are at the pilot that is at that locus
so here I've like highlighted
like you might have three reads
overlapping to them are a one is see
what do you want to do with that do you
want to say that that C is an error or
that person has a heterozygous a to C
mutation there the reference wasn't a so
that's very just like you dumped some
application logic on it and then the
distributed systems work it's kind of
done um so yeah this is all basically
built and the infrastructure works and
we are kind of in the place where we're
iterating on that application logic
portion so we have our Hadoop cluster
it's like a hundred nodes 2400 cores
that we run it on and it goes you know
can process a whole genome in ten to
twenty minutes
compare that with one of the tools you
might use otherwise on the right side
here which is take two and a half hours
just to run on chromosome one the way
that people usually run these things in
production tools that are not massively
parallel like guacamole is like you
basically just like you split up the
data manually yourself by what
chromosome it's on it's just sort of a
coarse-grained way that you can that you
can do things and now and the chromosome
one is the largest chromosome so
generally if you do that work you can
have the entire thing run in the amount
of time that the tool takes to process
chromosome one it's you know it works
but it's sort of unfortunate it's it's
coarse-grained number one and you sort
of leak a lot of your paralyzation logic
all the way up into your workflow
managers that are now moving around like
22 files for the different chromosomes
and you're running all these different
jobs it's like you know it's I think
there's a lot of opportunity to just
have these things be built in the way so
such that they run in a natively
massively parallel way and can be just
kind of run elastically on public clouds
or whatever so that's great then the
next step is sort of like okay well
let's take all that like pile up logic
we want to look at like okay how many
reads match to reference how many were
variants what else is happening on the
read are the qualities of these reads
high or low and like all these other
things we want to look at and just put
some machine learning on it and that's
sort of like the next step that we're
kind of working on now
a big problem under underlying a lot of
the difficulty in the space is that
there's not a lot of validated data like
we don't actually know the ground truth
in any of these somatic genomes any of
these cancer genomes like did it
actually have the mutation there or not
if we sequence the same patient like
some months later their cancer has
evolved and also we don't have a way to
like generate ground truth sequencing
very easily that's sort of the point
like this these pipelines were supposed
to sequence the genome so we kind of
like don't know where we're wrong a lot
of the like validation work that happens
will basically take a bunch of calls
that existing callers have output and
then go like deeply sequence the genome
at those positions to try to validate
those calls and so that can tell you
true positives and false positives but
it can't tell you true negatives or
false negatives I guess is like one
problem that sort of underpins a lot of
the studies here so we're also in
parallel kind of trying to curate a lot
of like to the extent to which any
validated data sources exist that we can
then just like run a bunch of models on
that's like something we're actively
working on as well okay there's just
like one other thing I was going to talk
about how we're doing on time with okay
cool I'll try to breeze through this so
I had to write recently a kind of
interesting distributed algorithm for a
QC analysis problem I want to do on some
genome data so up until now we've talked
all about genome sequencing much more
commonly done in practice is exome
sequencing which is just where you
sequence just the genes part of the
genome which is actually only like 1% of
it I you sort of don't bother with all
the other junk that I talked about
before the downside of this is well
another upside is it's a lot cheaper so
and so many many mrs. Ben done too many
more genomes than whole genome
sequencing um a downside is that the the
one percent you're trying to get is not
like just like one percent at the front
it's like just it's like 10,000
fragments scattered all over the genome
that are the genes and so for each one
you sort of like you have like special
adapters that bind to the region of the
genome on either side of the thing
you're trying to capture and so you dump
that in with the genome you just pull
out the bits that there's it
mine too so it's a much more intricate
kind of like sequencing process in some
ways and you're much more prone to
having those adapters just kind of like
if the person has a mutation and in the
place next to the gene that the adapter
was supposed to bind then you might just
miss that gene so like it's very common
that you have this data and you're and
that you're like is did this even get
what we wanted it to get and we don't
necessarily know so the question that I
want to answer here is basically like of
the genes we were trying to capture in
an exome sequencing run how many had at
least X reads covering the normal sample
and Y reads covering the tumor sample x
and y are important because that sort of
has a bearing on the statistical power
that we have downstream when we're
variant calling right like if only three
reads cover a thing cover a locus you
can't really say with high confidence
that there is or is not a variant there
so the the plot that we're trying to
ultimately generate is looks something
like this where you have like the x-axis
is the depth in the tumor sample the
y-axis is the depth and the normal
sample and what the shading represents
is the percentage of the genes that we
tried to capture that we did in fact
capture at at least that x and y depth
right so like this is saying like 93
percent of the not the genes of the
actual like low-side that comprised
those genes that we wanted to get are
covered with at least 30 reads in the
tumor in 10 reads in the normal and so
that would give us like a certain amount
of power to like say certain things
about the variants that we found there
um so the way that I computed this was
basically you take all of these reads
and you can do the first kind of like
word count transformation that I
described before where you just say like
for every locus that the read covers you
admit that locus comma 1 you count them
up so you have like okay here's that
locus comma how many reads cover it and
you're doing that sort of for both the
tumor and the normal samples so you'd
say so for each locus you have how many
reads covered in the normal sample and
how many reads cover it in the tumor
sample I mean sort of like invert that
tuple to count up how many lows I have
that coverage in the normal and to
a sample . so like we'll have like a
tuple that's like 30 comma 10 comma 1
and we count those up and we want to
that that will tell us how many of the
low-side we were trying to capture had
exactly 30 reads covering it in the
normal I'm sorry in the tumor and 10
reads covering it in the normal and then
we want to and you can think of that as
sort of like a PDF of a joint
probability distribution we're basically
trying to compute the CDF so it's like a
long convoluted explanation to they were
basically just doing like a distributed
two-dimensional prefix um so I made like
a small visualization of how that works
so like if we start we have this matrix
and the small boxes here you can think
of as like spark partitions that have
some integers and this is key to sort of
like this is this would be like the
tumor depth down here and the normal
depth there and so it'd be like 1 2 3
through 9 and 1 2 3 through 9 so that 2
in the upper right means that like there
are two of the low side that we were
trying to sequence had eight depth in
the tumor and eight depth in the normal
and we basically want to take each
element in this matrix and replace it
with the sum of all elements that are
above or to the right of it across all
the partitions in the matrix and
including itself that sort of makes
sense so first thing we do is within
each partition we just do a a pre a this
sort of two dimensional prefix um so
like we just look at the upper right
partition we had like it's basically all
0 at 2 5 and 1 so the tube stays at 2
that's the sum of everything up and to
the right of it
this 7 is where the 5 is the 5 had this
5 in this 2 this was a 0 which gets the
2 from above that's like the sum of this
rectangle up in to the right of it and 8
is sort of the sum of this entire
partition
right so all the you know all of our
mappers just do this to each small box
in isolation right so now what we're
going to do is basically ship around the
leftmost column bottommost row and
bottom-left element from
partition to all of the partitions that
are to the left of it below it and below
and to the left of it
respectively so I have like a small
animation of what's happening there so
like this partition is going to send its
left column over here and over here it's
going to send its bottom row down here
and down here and it's going to send its
total partition sum to all four
partitions that are below into the left
of it right and then this one's only
sending each of those three things to
one other partition and so on and so
forth
so then on the receiving end like this
partition down here it's going to
receive like this row from the partition
above it this row from the partition
above it this column from the partition
to the right of it this column for the
position right of it and also this
screen element from the four partitions
that are up and to the right of it and
so that's enough for it to say okay I
know my own like intra partition partial
sums so like this element needs
basically the column sum from this
partition the column sum from this
partition the row sum from this
partition the row sum from this
partition and the screen numbers from
all these which encapsulate all of the
data that is sort of up into the right
of it so you sort of like then basically
just like one giant shuffle step but
that is like linear in the size of the
entire data set so it's fine and you get
your entire like global prefix some out
of it and so that's sort of like how I
was able to generate this plot where you
just had like you know the the maximum
death can actually goes out a good deal
past a thousand here so anyway so
there's a just I think a lot of
opportunities for just like rewriting
and existing bioinformatics tools and
also writing new ones that don't exist
to solve a lot of the questions that
people in some cases aren't even asking
because they are mostly just tailoring
the questions they ask to things that
they can answer with constraint
computational resources so doing all
that in like sort of massively parallel
settings like using tools like spark and
the Hadoop stack has been pretty like
interesting process for me and for the
lab
and I think that was all that had so
thank you
[Applause]